[Musik]
14.15 habe ich angefangen mit tattoos
stechen zu lassen er feierte den
erneuten mythologie für den gott tiefer
oder tür die rhone symbolisiert
ursprünglich gerechtigkeit sie ist ein
zeichen des krieges auch in der
subkultur der white power skinheads ist
sie das symbol des krieges ein krieger
der bereit ist für seine rasse zu töten
ja und deswegen habe ich sie mir ins
gesicht tätowieren lassen
dass entweder die leute wussten was sie
bedeutet oder eben nicht und wer es
nicht wusste würde es schon noch früh
genug mit kriegen das war die idee ich
hatte mich darauf eingestellt entweder
in den knast zu kommen oder bald
draufzugehen
[Musik]
breitner wurde mit 14 jahren skinhead
das war 1991
16 jahre lang gehörte er verschiedene
neonazi skinhead organisationen an unter
anderem war er bei den autor henner
skins der blood and honour bewegung und
dem win länder social club
es war meine tiefste überzeugung dass
wir die herrenrasse sind schließlich
haben wir die moderne gesellschaft die
wirtschaft und eigentlich alles erfunden
und deshalb ist es unser gott gegebenes
recht uns zu nehmen was uns zusteht aber
die weiße rasse stadt aus also mussten
wir zu extrem mitteln greifen um unser
volk zu werten
was ist denn für dich extrem damals war
für mich nicht mal im ort was besonderes
sowas ist halt passiert jetzt im
nachhinein einfach aus einem fahrenden
auto
zur es ist schon krass
wir beobachten viele extremistische
organisationen und die skinhead bewegung
gehört ganz sicher zu den
gewalttätigsten auf brian würden wir
aufmerksam als er auf verschiedenen
skinhead retten auftauchte und auf den
überwachungsfotos zu sehen war
so eine art pitbull der bewegung an
direkter aggressiver typ er trank gerne
bier ging keinem streit aus dem weg und
hatte den ruf ein schläger zu sein
15 ließ sich mehr hass auf die knöchel
tätowieren das wort hass hatte mir schon
immer gefallen ich fand das einfach
richtig damals mit 17 18 kam die
hakenkreuze und die eisernen kreuz ich
bin damals voll aufgegangen dieser
ganzen nazis kinderkiste
abzeichen spricht für sich ohne das bist
du kein richtiger nazi in den späten
achtzigern und frühen 90ern musste man
sich das noch verdienen das heißt einen
angehörigen einer minderheit angreifen
und zu boden schlagen so habe ich meine
vor drei jahren auch verdient
sich die tattoos stechen ließ glaubt er
nicht dass er mal eine familie haben
würde aber dann trat er an mein leben in
unser leben er wurde ein ehemann und
sein vater früher hätte er nie gedacht
mal so ein leben zu führen
eines kinder und nazi organisationen die
ich mit gegründet habe ich habe mir
vertrag auf dem bauch tätowieren lassen
fragt steht für schläger und wir bei
anschlägen
es ist der nazi aspekt ich habe beides
kombiniert und das wurde eine art motto
für viele von uns
ich habe mich an seine tattoos gewöhnt
ich weiß ja wer er wirklich ist im
gegensatz zu den leuten auf der straße
die nur nach seinen tattoos beurteilen
wurde von
dem sänger von school driver
es war eines kinder bewegung in den
späten siebzigern frühen achtzigern
die 18 steht für den ersten und achten
buchstaben des alphabets also a und h
für adolf hitler
auf die welt kam
es war ein unfassbar großes seltsames
intensives gefühl dass ich so
wahrscheinlich nie wieder erleben werde
ich hasse erste mal mein kind im arm zu
halten diese liebe zu spielen das war
einfach überwältigend ich kann es gar
nicht in worte fassen er ist mein ein
und alles sagt er ihn würde ich alles
tun und ihm möchte ich all das geben ihr
dass ich nie
hatte ich immer ein rasiermesser dabei
eher kneipenschlägereien und ich habe
mir das als markenzeichen und auch als
warnung ins gesicht tätowieren lassen so
nach dem motto quatsch nicht an oder ich
schlitz dich auch
warum ein rasiermesser was hatten denn
deine kumpels dabei
viele hatten schlagringe oder pistolen
dabei zur sache ich stehe auch drauf
aber mein ding ist er der kampf mann
gegen mann
das fand ich immer geiler als auf leute
auf der anderen straßenseite zu ballern
das rasiermesser war immer meine
lieblingswaffe und so einen
messerschnitt richtet vielmehr an hat
eine normale stichwunden damit kann man
richtig was kaputt machen
es gab immer mal wieder situationen die
ich nicht mit fäusten und tritten regeln
konnte
und zum beispiel drei vier typen
gleichzeitig in einer kneipe auf mich
los ging das ding raus geholt und ein
paar von denen aufgeschlitzt dann war
ruhe es hat immer gut funktioniert
oder wenn ich jemanden eine lektion fürs
leben erteilen wollte dann habe ich mein
messer benutzt
wie denkst du heute über die tattoos in
deinem gesicht sie machen mich sie
erinnern mich ständig an ein teil meines
lebens für mich abgeschlossen habe
breitner wuchs in albuquerque new mexico
auf
als ich ungefähr 3 war zog ich mit
meiner kleinen schwester zu unseren
großeltern meine oma war schwere
alkoholiker horn
da kam dauernd zu hören dass sich
wertlos bin und nie was auf die reihe
kriegen würde mit 14 15 fing ich an von
zu hause weggelaufen
ich bin immer wieder was sich dann auf
der straße landete
mit 18 jahren schloss sich brian
erstmals einer white power skinhead
bewegung an
als teenager hatte ich keine familie
alles was ich hatte waren meine freunde
eigentlich war meine kumpels meine
familie normalerweise gehen leute nicht
in irgendwelche gangs weise das cool
finden sondern weil sie straßenkinder
und die nichts und niemanden haben
brian van zunehmend gefallen an gewalt
er zog nach indiana und schloss sich
dort den autor henner skins an eine
gruppe von hardcore skinheads die aus
dem nationalen dachverband der
sogenannten hemmer skination
rausgeflogen waren
die skins genossen großen respekt und
waren überall gefürchtet wenn ein hai
masken auf einer party auftauchte wusste
jeder bescheid und schlich auf leisen
sohlen um die herum sie waren für ihre
unfassbare brutalität und härte
berichtet
keiner wollte ihn in die quere kommen
und alle wollten bei ihnen mitmachen
ich war ein sogenannter pitbull sie
zeigten auf jemanden und ich ging auf
ihn los in einer unserer jungs in einer
bar blöd angemacht wurde zeigten sie auf
ihn und ich hab den typen fertig gemacht
wir waren eine extrem harte truppe
richtig
unser slogan im internet leg dich nicht
mit uns an wir bringen dich um das war
unsere philosophie und die lebt hier
auch wenn du dir in der szene schnell
einen namen machen willst musst du
extrem brutal skinheads stehen auf
gewalt das ist einfach ihr ding das ist
der lebensstil wenn wir unterwegs waren
hatten wir immer schusswaffen
baseballschläger und messer im auto wenn
dann ein schwarzer mit einem weißen
mädchen rum lief sind für einen block
weiter gefahren ausgestiegen und haben
sie über feind zwei andere gingen um den
block und kam von hinten so dass sie
nicht abbauen konnten
wie lange hat so was normalerweise
gedauert für ein überfall lange gedauert
hat warum das 10 15 sekunden also rein
raus ja ja danach sind wir abgehoben und
haben das groß gefeiert das hieß wir uns
einfach spaß haben
anderen weh zu tun war für uns spaß
erst dann war ich beim arzt ich wollte
wissen wie ich meine tattoos und gesicht
und am hals los werden kann
naja man kriegt die weg das ist das gute
er will am 22
eine laser op machen das wird wohl
ziemlich schmerzhaft
das könnte sein es ist möglich dass
narben entstehen aber das risiko ist
eher gering
mit einem laser wir brennen auf der haut
machst du dir sorgen denn der die sich
seine tattoos weg machen lässt ja angst
dass du dir die nicht mehr erkennt ihn
nichts mehr erkennen
der die sieht gut aus aber ohne sie wird
großartig aussehen
ich glaube die heilung könnte ein
bisschen weh tun aber ich bin sicher ihr
macht das spaß
auf schmerzen
das ergebnis was meinst du wie findest
du das denn die seine tattoos weg machen
lässt
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
als ich klein war war rassismus was ganz
normales ich weiß noch genau wie mein
der die dauernd das n wort sagte
nach dem release eltern sich scheiden
ließen wohnte sie abwechselnd bei ihrer
mutter in arizona und ihrem vater in
detroit
ich war ein ganz schlimmer rassist
natürlich wollte ich nicht dass meine
kinder das mitkriegen
aber wenn sie länger bei mir waren haben
sie das natürlich mitgekriegt weil ich
eben ein rassist war
als kind wurde uns eingetrichtert dass
minderheiten und schwarze parzellen sind
wir gehen nicht hin wo sie hingingen wir
setzen uns nicht dahin wo sie saßen wir
waren was besseres als sie das war
nochmal die schwarzen und die anderen
minderheiten waren kakerlaken bürger
zweiter klasse
[Musik]
ich kam über meinen ex mann in die
bewegung er hatte vier jahre im
gefängnis gesessen und war dort in die
szene gekommen
mit 29 schloss sich julie der national
alliance an die national alliance ist
eine neonazi bewegung aber ihre
mitgliederinnen nicht mit hakenkreuzen
und braunhemden rum sie gehen subtiler
vor denn sie wissen dass sie viel mehr
bewirken können wenn sie von innerhalb
des systems agieren
[Musik]
wir haben propaganda gemacht flyer
verteilt versucht die medien auf uns
aufmerksam zu machen und mitglieder
angeworben
das wort für unsere waffe könnte man
sagen
[Musik]
nach 16 jahren in der neonazi bewegung
waren brian und seine frau julie
desillusioniert trotz wiederholter
morddrohungen stiegen sie aus
[Musik]
man muss sich darüber im klaren sein
dass in dieser szene tod vor schande
geht und wenn jemand der bewegung den
rücken kehrt dann ist das eine schande
die reflexartige reaktion ist dann
meistens einschüchterung und gewalt
und julie packten ihre sachen und
verließen hier zu hause in michigan sie
zogen nach tennessee um näher bei julies
vater zu sein aber der neuanfang war
nicht leicht
als kind habe ich mich nie um arbeit
gestört das einzige was mich
interessiert aber am pool gelang aber
wenn du eine familie versorgen muss
sieht die sache plötzlich ganz anders
aus meistens finden die leute
irgendwelche ausreden warum sie mich
nicht einstellen können statt zuzugeben
dass ich meine visage nicht passt
wir machen das zusammen
ich helfe ihm dabei nach jobs zu suchen
in anzeigen im internet und in der
zeitung aber wenn er dann von der
jobsuche nach hause kommt ist das
meistens ziemlich ernüchternd
dann ist er deprimiert und ich muss ihn
wieder aufbauen
jetzt weiß ich genau wie sie sich
anfühlt schwarz zu sein wenn wegen
seines aussehens diskriminiert wirst ich
kann mich damit jetzt gut identifizieren
[Musik]
völlig pleite und arbeitslos hatte brian
keine ahnung wie er seine hass tattoos
entfernen lassen sollte bis hilfe von
unerwarteter seite kam
das southern poverty law center ist eine
gemeinnützige
bürgerrechtsorganisation die
extremistische gruppierungen verfolgt
und vor gericht bringt
rein kontaktierte uns nach der
veröffentlichung unseres artikels über
den winter in der social club dem er
angehört hatte
die bürgerrechtler 3 und lori mut baten
brian und juli um ein treffen
ich habe eine menge leute kennengelernt
die aussteigen wollen und es einfach
nicht schaffen hinter all den tattoos
steckt eine familie die daraus wollte
und zurück in die gesellschaft für sich
und für ihre kinder
am ersten treffen haben wir natürlich
auch über die tattoos in meinem gesicht
geredet das ist immer thema damals hatte
ich gerade bei ebay nach einer säure
gewissen prise mehr weg setzen
als ich das hörte war ich schockiert
dass er so was in betracht zieht das
southern poverty law center erklärte
sich bereit die kosten von brians
tattooentfernung zu übernehmen
wenn ich nur ein kind davon abhalten
kann die gleichen fehler zu machen wie
ich und damit verhindere dass eine
andere familie den gleichen scheiß
durchmachen muss sie meine vielleicht
kann ich dadurch wieder etwas gut machen
wie das ganze bekommt einen sinn
[Musik]
die schwierigkeit bei dreien ist dass es
so viele tätowierungen sind müssen sie
nicht große teile seiner haut behandeln
das ist die herausforderung
dr brust check the brians tätowierungen
stufenweise behandeln und sie stück für
stück vom gesicht zum hals vorarbeiten
für die gesamte behandlung rechnet er
mit acht bis zwölf sitzungen
ich werde jetzt einen kleinen
empfindlichkeit test machen oh
ja dann müssen wir ihn betäuben das war
nicht so angenehm wurde nein überhaupt
nicht es tut echt weh alles klar ich
werde ihnen eine betäubung geben
tut mir leid aber
dann spielen sie nichts mehr
da können wir diese großflächig
verteilten tätowierungen nicht mit nur
einer spitze teure sind einfach zu viele
sind auch nicht die kleinen einstichen
die will tun sondern das
lokalanästhetikum hat ein leicht sauren
ph-wert deswegen wenn das bei jedem
günstig wenn man einen großen bereich
behandeln muss sind das sehr viele
infektionen das ist nicht sehr angenehm
schön entspannen
das ist eine empfindliche stelle
ok ich weiß das ist viel
früher habe ich zu den leuten im
tattoo-studio immer gesagt ihr seid
löschen
das wegmachen es viel schmerzhafter als
das stechen leider
brender kommt ungefähr 30 spritzen in
seine rechte gesichtshälfte
ich weiß das ist dies die nase kommt
erst noch
die habe ich mir für den schluss
aufgehoben ich muss lieber nicht
ansprechen
ich werde im unteren bereich anfangen
erst etwas weniger schmerzempfindlich
fast geschafft
ist geschafft
das war's
[Musik]
rücken sie die kompresse darf hier
machen wir kleine pause ok kommen sie
wieder zu hatten das war der fiese teil
ich möchte zu ihm ich dreh durch
ich war bisher immer dabei bei allem das
ist ein komisches gefühl
dabei könnte ich ja sowieso nichts
machen außer seiner hand halten wie
sonst auch aber vielleicht würde ich das
auch nicht aushalten und musste wieder
raus
ich habe john lee beim nordic fürs 2005
kennengelernt
kämpft am wochenende hörst du die bands
an und trinkt bier und sie war mit ihren
kindern
warum
sie verfasst drei jahre alt sie ging zu
ihm zog an seinem bein und wollte ein
foto von ihm
das weiß ich noch so fragte ich ihn ob
er was dagegen hätte sich mit ihr
fotografieren zu lassen dann habe ich
ein foto gemacht und so haben wir uns
kennengelernt
sie haben das foto gemacht und ich habe
kurz mit julie gequatscht vielleicht
cool ich dachte wow was für ein tolles
mädchen
wir haben auf dem auge fest eigentlich
gar nicht viel miteinander gesprochen
das fing erst ein paar monate später am
telefon
haben nächtelang darüber geredet was wir
uns im leben wünschen dass wir bei
deiner familie wollen über unsere
kindheit und so sie war sehr offen und
ich hörte er gern zu sie war einfach
wir haben ja nur telefoniert aber ich
dachte oft dass es viel einfacher ist
jemanden so kennen zu lernen weil keine
angst davor hat abgestempelt zu werden
ich kam nach einer kneipenschlägerei
nach hause und da echt genervt und
ziemlich besoffen ich hab sie einfach
angerufen und ihr einen antrag gemacht
ich hatte die schnauze einfach voll ich
wollte endlich eine familie
und sie hat ja gesagt dass sie verrückt
ist
wir haben vor einem friedensrichter der
heiratet ich habe mich im ernst mit
jemandem verlobt die nicht nur einmal
getroffen hatte mit dem ich sonst nur
telefoniert hatte schon verrückt
ich liebe meine frau ist mein fels in
der brandung sie ist ein geschenk gottes
mehr gibt es nicht zu sagen sie hat mir
das leben
haben alle ihre schutzbrille auf wir
versuchen es noch mal okay besser so
viel besser
wir beginnen vorsichtig und gucken wie
die haut reagiert
es dürfen keine blutungen entstehen da
nur diese kleinen weißen stellen auf
manchen bereichen ist die tinte etwas
tiefer unter der haut
schon sagt er ab und zu werden sie einen
stich spüren und onlinebereich nicht
ganz taub geworden ist
das knallen dass sie hören ist die
explosion eines farbpigments und viele
kleinere teilchen
okay jetzt kommt der große teil
und wie lange hält die betäubung an für
ein paar stunden
und wenn sie am klint werden sie merken
wie es anfängt zu brennen es tut mir
leid
tut das weh ganz schön
wir machen woanders weiter
gleich geschafft
wir sind vielleicht durch drehen sie
bitte ihren kopf hast du mir
ich denke das war's
gut gemacht jetzt erste mal war das echt
tat ich weiß aber sie war nicht ab danke
[Musik]
in den ersten stunden nach der
behandlung war meine haut noch getoppt
als dieses zeugs nach links fühlte es
sich an als hätte jemand mein gesicht
mit einem propangasbrenner bearbeitet
das war hart er wachte mitten in der
nacht auf und hatte wahnsinnige
schmerzen und mit den schwellungen
hatten wir nicht gerechnet
sie ziemlich beschissen aus
der arzt hat erzählt dass es sich
anfühlen würde wie der schlimmste
sonnenbrand meines lebens im moment ist
es so als ob mir jemand mit einem
stiefel ins gesicht getreten hätte das
brennen ist gar nicht so schlimm aber
die schwellungen tun richtig weh ich
sehe aus als hätte mich jemanden mit dem
baseballschläger vertauschen und so
fühlt es sich auch an
kommt mich mal an es ist noch mehr
angespannt
das sieht schlimm aus
das gesicht besonders um die augen ist
recht empfinden war das auch so heißt du
die tattoos bekommen wenn ich ganz okay
als ich mir die tattoos um die augen
herum stechen lassen ab hatte ich danach
ein veilchen am liebsten würde ich mir
jetzt eine narbe reinstecken um der
druck rauszunehmen aber das wäre keine
gute
[Musik]
ich hoffe dass die schwellungen mit dem
eis zurück gehen aber er lässt sich
nicht entmutigen er sagt das gehört dazu
es tut mir weh ihn so leiden zu sehen
aber alles hat seinen preis
[Musik]
kurz vor seiner zweiten behandlung
bekommt brian besuch von seinem alten
freund erik meijer
es ist das erste mal dass bryan nach
seinem ausstieg aus der skinhead szene
einen seiner alten freunde wieder sieht
in den ersten nächten haben wir viel
über frühe geräten wir haben uns immer
in fünf jahre lang nicht gesehen
das war schon auch emotional denn jutta
menge freunde gewesen aber nach ein paar
tagen war alles wieder single
wir versuchen ein paar von den
rassistischen tattoos zu überdecken die
gangster tattoos ein bisschen sein image
aufpolieren
aus dem gesicht weg machen das heißt
nicht dass ich das jetzt grundsätzlich
hasse wie schon auf den armen und so ist
das ja auch sozial akzeptiert
seit etwa sechs monaten planen wir uns
zu treffen
ich dachte er wäre noch in der szene das
wäre eine falle und ich zusammen zu
schlagen oder umzubringen ich war eine
zeitlang nicht sonderlich beliebt im
club
wir werden immer misstrauisch seien
demgegenüber
wir wissen ja aber zu die fähig sind
wir haben uns kennengelernt als ich so
14 15 war das war bei einer kundgebung
des plans in denver colorado
es war am gedenktag für martin luther
king aber wir haben gedacht wir haben
gesagt das ist der jailbreak tag und
nicht der martin luther king gedenkt
ich bin so um 2004 um ausgestiegen
damals hatte ich ein ziemliches
drogenproblem ein paar leute von weiter
oben in der hierarchie hatten es auf
mich abgesehen einmal schließlich bei
einem freund auf der couch und wurde mit
einer knarre fast totgeschlagen
eigentlich wollten die mich auch killen
aber er hat gesagt sie seien es lassen
ich verdanke diesen typen mein leben
der jungs im club war sehr schlecht zu
sprechen
bei einer versammlung schlug er vor eric
umbringen zu lassen
ich war einer von zwei leuten die
aufgestanden sind und nein gesagt haben
er wurde damals sowieso schon von hallen
geschnitten und war gestraft genug
brauchten wir ihn doch nicht zu
den sohn von dem typen halt gemacht
hätte wäre das was anderes aber er hatte
nur ein drogenproblem deswegen wollte
dieser typ in köln das war die einzige
wird nur
wer wild zu gucken
hast du eine volle windel
erfolgs nur für
stück acker gemacht und sagt mama ich
dachte mir ich hab es gerochen und
sagt mama
ich hab dich lieben geht zu mama
nachts war ziemlich hart ich bin so um
halb drei aufgewacht bin ich wieder
eingeschlafen um 7 wieder aufgestanden
die schmerzen sind kaum zu ertragen
es fühlt sich an als ob mein gesicht
gleich platz
nicht
und das macht sich traurig
ich fragte ob er mit dem augenwinkel
und er sagt nicht viel
ich fahre jetzt in die apotheke um seine
schmerztabletten abzuholen die zweite
behandlung fand ich noch schlimmer weil
ich ja wusste wie stark die schmerzen
beim ersten mal waren es
ist hart jemanden leiden zu sehen den
man so liebt
am tag danach tut es einfach tierisch
war die schwellung und der druck auf
meinem gesicht es tut einfach scheiß
will im krankenhaus wegen die
schwellungen an dem nachhauseweg ging es
dann richtig los und gegen 10 uhr
gestern haben weil mein auge schon fast
komplett zu jetzt wird es immer
schlimmer
besuch ist haben die beiden viel geredet
und dabei sind alte runden aufgebrochen
sachen die sie damals gemacht haben
sachen die er vergessen wollte die er
sich gerne verzeihen würde
da kam viel wieder hoch was er
durchgemacht und getan hat und das hat
ihn ziemlich fertig gemacht
[Musik]
guck dir das foto an das ist bryan hatte
anfing sich das gesicht tätowieren zu
lassen auf dem bild machte einen auf
gangster und ist total dicht
das habe ich geschwärzt daher war
[Musik]
dieses foto wurde in der nacht gemacht
als brian aufgenommen wurde
in dieser nacht wurde ich mitglied auf
probe und er wurde festes mitglied der
nacht habe ich meinen alter zur maske
abgelegt alle mitglieder standen im
kreis und hatten fackeln in der hand und
wieder aufgenommen wurde musste von den
präsidenten treten eine hand auf das
abzeichen legen die andere auf einer
waffe und eine blutspur ablehnen
dass man dem klub und allen mitgliedern
die treue schwört bis zum tod und bereit
ist für sie zu töten und zu sterben
es war für ihn und auch für mich ein
wirklich besonderer moment damals
das war der lohn für 15 monate harte
arbeit in der nacht wurde mag auch zum
euro
ein offizieller unterstützer um ein
hemmers kind zu werden muss man durch
mehrere stadien erst mal bist du
anwärter für mindestens sechs monate
dann wirst du ein uhu wieder mindestens
sechs monate das monate und dann wirst
du für mindestens sechs monate mitglied
auf probe ein jahr auf probe
ja das ist ein bekanntes motiv in der
white power bewegung
um seinen hals legt eine schlinge es
zeigt ein lynchmord einem schwarzen
was geht ihnen durch den kopf wenn sie
sich all diese wieder heute ansehen
ich kann nicht glauben wäre ich damals
war wie sehr ich mich verändert haben
und so eine einstellung zu allem weiter
akzeptiere ich andere menschen so wie
sie sind das zu sehen ist
in welcher hinsicht ich kann nicht
glauben dass dieser mensch da ich war
dass ich dass ich wie soll ich das
erklären so wenig respekt vor anderen
menschen hatte so wenig respekt vor dem
leben anderer menschen
für mich gab es nur die die auf den
fotos zu sehen sind für den rest der
welt habe ich mich ein scheiß
interessiert so war es dass wir unsere
familie
sobald du mitglied der organisation
wirst entfremdet du dich von allem und
jedem aus seinem früheren leben sie sind
eine neue familie und außerhalb davon
existiert gar nichts mehr wie er gesagt
hat außerhalb dieser szene gibt es
nichts und niemandem halt und irgendwann
glaubst du dass alle anderen da draußen
einfach keinen schimmer haben du
entfernt sich immer weiter vom normalen
leben
früher habe ich jeden tag mit meiner
mutter geredet dann noch einmal in der
woche und am ende nur noch einmal im
monat das ist fast wie eine sekte du
gibst alles auf was dir früher wichtig
war weil nur doch dass ein erzählt
niemand außerhalb der organisation weiß
was eigentlich wirklich sache ist die
sind alle ahnungslos es ist wirklich wie
eine sekte
mir schwer mir selbst weil ich einfach
einen haufen scheiße gemacht habe um mir
diese tattoos auf meinen armen und die
abzeichen an meiner brust zu verdienen
das kommt immer wieder ich habe echt
vielen menschen die das nicht verdient
haben wirklich schlimme dinge angetan
jedes mal wenn ich mir die bilder an
coco oder daran denke eigentlich wieder
an dem selben punkt ich kann hier nicht
vergeben ich war ein erwachsener mann
ich hätte es besser wissen müssen als
mich hier ein dummer schläger
aufzuführen was in der bibel steht
vergibt ihr selbst einen gott vergibt
die weißt du vielleicht vergibt
aber mir fällt es echt schwer mir diesen
ganzen scheiß zu verzeihen es ist
ekelerregend oder
manchmal fühlt man sich das an und denke
es ist enttäuschend es ist nicht mal
mehr widerliches macht mich auch nicht
mehr wütend ich bin einfach total
enttäuscht von meinem eigenen
entscheidungen ich kann nachts nicht
schlafen wegen der scheiße die ich mit
leuten gemacht habe und die ich erlebt
habe ich lege die ganze nacht lang wache
und grünen das ist echt hart wirklich
hat ich hab damit noch nicht
abgeschlossen
er klärt du bist ganz schön waren
bist du okay
das lässt das schmerzmittel nach
[Musik]
bei der dritten behandlung wird sich
doch der scheck das erste mal um ryans
hals kümmern
ich gebe ihnen jetzt ein paar
beruhigungsmittel ok schließt die
monitore an
weil der hals sehr schmerzempfindlich
ist wird brian unter vollnarkose
behandelt
während er im tiefschlaf liegt will dr
scheck sich auch um sein gesicht kümmern
der schutz brille aufsetzen und zwölf in
meinen black sagt der unterschied
zwischen mir und dir ist war mir sieht
cool aus
[Gelächter]
besonders heiß brennt wenn es irgendwann
aus so war es bei den himmel skins wir
waren so krass das ist so nicht mehr
wind sich und noch ein paar andere die
mit den autor henner skins abhängen
beschlossen eine eigene gruppe zu
gründen die gesamte light power bewegung
anzuwenden sie gründeten die who said
skinheads mein job war es einzelne
ortsverbände aufzubauen wenn ich eine
neue gruppe aufgebaut hatte setzt sich
einen anführer ein und zog weiter in die
nächste stadt es war der perfekte job
für mich und ich hatte ja keine familie
also kam ich ganz schön denn der lokalen
szene besuchte ich nach typen die was
draufhaben rekrutierte sie und nahmen
ihre kumpels gleich mit sie waren im
grunde massen rekrutierungs tun damit
wir es mit der hamas genössen auf
minuten
in mehreren staaten unterwegs um neue
skinhead gruppen aufzubauen
aber wir hatten irgendwann 56 staaten
also beschlossen wir alle gruppen zu
einer gemeinsamen organisation
zusammenzuschließen die neue
organisation wurde wenn länder social
club genannt die win landes übernahmen
andere gruppen wie die hus und die ohio
state skins ihr ziel war es noch
radikaler als die hammers dance nation
zu sein so nach dem motto wenn ihr mit
einem messer ankommt ziehen die eine
knarre wenn ihr einen von uns zusammen
schlag töten wir einen von euch wenn
landes und die hamas die nation waren de
facto im kriegszustand
während dieser zeit wurde bryant zum
schweren alkoholiker
ich habe 30 dosen bier am tag getrunken
und wenn es nicht reicht dann woanders
30 bier und eine flasche whiskey ich war
dabei mich zu tode zu saufen
mir ging es echt beschissen statt was zu
ändern wollte ich sterben das ist die
scanner philosophie in den ruhestand
gehen heißt entweder knast oder friedhof
ich hatte keinen bock auf knast lebe
also nur noch der tod
[Musik]
wir haben
bringen sie jetzt in den aufwachraum
bleiben sie auf dem rücken liegen wenn
sie mich
bleiben sie liegen würden
das gesicht
wenn sie junge typen aus der narkose
aufrechnen wollen sie am liebsten gleich
aufstehen und allen zeigen wie stark sie
sind
bringen sie jetzt in den aufwachraum
ich glaube er macht sich mehr sorgen um
mich als um alles andere
er will dass ich ihn sehr damit ich weiß
dass er okay ist ich bin nun mal eine
mutter und mache mir immer sorgen viel
zu viele
seien blutdruck ist jetzt bei 179 208
den müssen auf das niveau von
denkt an bord
gott
rain wird besser
nun ist kein schmerz 10 am schlimmsten
ist es mit 10
wir glauben der schmerz wird stärker
weil die narkose allmählich nachlässt
auch das zittern ist ganz normal für
patienten die aus der narkose aufwachen
wir geben ihm etwas dagegen es ist gut
dass sie da ist und ihn beruhigt alles
wird gut
sie bekommen jetzt noch ein
schmerzmittel am anfang haben mich die
beiden schon eingeschüchtert von den
anderen krankenschwestern hatte ich ja
schon ein bisschen was gehört dass er
eine menge tattoos im gesicht hat sie
wissen nicht was sie bedeuten aber auf
jeden fall nichts gutes ich hatte vorher
noch nie jemanden mit so vielen tattoos
im gesicht gesehen es war schon ein
kleiner schock
alles klar noch eine unterschrift das
ist für sie und dann können sie heim
unterschreiben sie heute keine wichtigen
papiere mehr okay
sie hatten eine vollnarkose sie hat
heute den hut auf hat immer den mutter
alles klar aber heute noch mehr als
sonst kannst du das wiederholen
du bist
[Applaus]
mein erster eindruck ist von kopf bis
fuß tätowiert er sieht aus wie ein
harter kerl wie ein krasser typ aber
nachdem ich eine weile mit ihm zu tun
hatte und ihn besser kennen gelernt
hatte habe ich gemerkt dass er
eigentlich ein softie ist hinter der
rauen schale steckt ein echt netter kerl
[Musik]
wir kommen langsam aber sicher voran es
geht allerdings nicht so schnell wie ich
am anfang der behandlung vor einigen
monaten gehofft hatte
[Musik]
am anfang dachten wir wir kriegen das in
sieben acht sitzungen hin aber jetzt ist
klar das reicht nicht die gesamte
behandlung könnte sich anderthalb jahre
hinziehen
nach mehreren sitzungen entscheidet sich
der arzt für eine neue vorgehensweise
wir versetzen ihn erst in vollnarkose
und wenn er schläft geben wir ihn dann
die lokalanästhesie das hat die letzten
male sehr gut funktioniert haben alle
ihre schulden auf dann kommt der laser
wenn er aufwacht ist ein gesicht noch
betäubt die lokalanästhesie klingt
langsam ab und der schmerz nimmt nach
und nach zu
dr scheck kann so bei jeder sitzung
bryans ganzes gesicht und seinen hals
lesern
aber die tinte ist sehr hartnäckig
wir wollen und den fortbestand der
weißen rasse sichern und die zukunft für
waisenkinder
das ist sowas wie das mantra des ski
netz
kinder sind unsere zukunft darum sind
wir hier je tiefer ich da reingeführt
desto klarer wurde mir dass es null
komma null um die kinder ging diese
typen misshandelten ihre frauen meisten
hatten nicht mal einen job es waren
einfach verbrecher runde jährliche
kinder im ganzen land hatten und keinen
cent unterhalt zahlte die predigten
jahner hohe ziele dort keiner hielt sich
daran
auf dem nordic fest auf dem sie brian
kennenlernte seit juli wie skinheads sex
mit minderjährigen mädchen hatten
waren zwei mädchen zelte untergingen die
typen rein und hatten sex mit ihnen
einer nach dem anderen die wechselten
sich ab
ich dachte mir diese typen interessieren
sich einen scheiß dafür wie alte mädchen
sind
das ist den total egal von wegen
arabische frau über verehrt und
geschätzt werden soll absolut lächerlich
das ist dem scheiß egal
und er hat sie mir das erzählte war ich
nicht im geringsten überrascht er dabei
schon 15 16 jahre lang genäht ich konnte
nichts mehr schocken
eine meiner töchter war damals 14
die vorstellung dass soetwas meinem kind
zustoßen könnte war für mich der
auslöser alles zu hinterfragen woran ich
die ganzen jahre geglaubt hatte
ich habe so oft mit angesehen wie meine
kumpels ihre frauen verprügelt haben
frauen kinder zu schlagen fand ich nie
besonders ruhig ich wollte nach den
gesetzen des krieges leben das bedeutet
lohr reiche schlachten zuschlag auf
eine sehr gute freundin von mir war im
neunten monat schwanger als ihr
langjähriger partner ihr ein blaues auge
verpasst
das ist die white power bewegung so was
passiert dort ständig irgendwann hatte
ich die schnauze einfach freuen und da
habe ich realisiert dass das was ich und
andere mehr jahrelang eingeredet hatten
nur einen haufen scheiße ist
wir waren beide an dem punkt dass wir
das alles einfach nur noch lächerlich
fanden aber da waren wir noch nicht
ausgestiegen wir hängen noch drin
als brian und julie aus der skinhead
bewegungen aussteigen wollten suchten
sie rat bei jemandem von der anderen
seite
[Musik]
nein das hast du nicht nicht auf kosten
meiner leute
jenkins betreibt die antirassistische
webseite von peoples projekt
juli war wohl mit ihrem latein am ende
und brauchte jemanden zum reden
es war offensichtlich dass sie probleme
hatte sie baten mich um hilfe und ich
wollte helfen ich sehe die leute erst
mal als menschen und nicht als gegner
erst das gespräch mit darryl dauerte
über drei stunden lang
er war gebildet und wusste wovon er
sprach wir standen auch die gleichen
sachen er war der sohn eines priesters
und kam aus der new yorker punk rock
szene
sie redeten über die szene die
musikszene wir hatten eine gemeinsame
ebene auf der wir miteinander
kommunizieren konnten und von da ging es
immer weiter
[Musik]
und je öfter ich mit ihm redete desto
klarer dass ich viel mehr mit ihnen
gemeinsam hat als mit den tüten mit
denen ich die letzten 20 jahre abgaben
er ist einfach ein großartiger
liebevoller typ er hat mein leben
verändert
[Musik]
hey hey guten morgen
wie sieht es mit den händen aus was
machen würde soll er sich heute darum
kümmern so lud dann machen wir das heute
ich habe aufgehört ihn wegen seiner
hände zu fragen ich dachte er hat schon
so viel mit seinem gesicht zu tun das
spreche ich lieber gar nicht an und die
taktik ist aufgegangen
jetzt hat er plötzlich gesagt er wie sie
machen lassen
das war mein allererstes tja ich brauche
es nicht mehr haben alle ihre
schutzhüllen auf
sehen sie wie gut das funktioniert
wahnsinn
[Musik]
ich bin jetzt schon so weit gegangen
dass in die hände der nächste logische
schritt dann kann ich was langärmliges
anziehen und so fast ganz normal
die kommen noch aus der zeit als er in
teenager war und gegen alles und jeden
rebellierte aber jetzt als erwachsene
und familienvater in der schule am
bankschalter beim händeschütteln alle
lesen immer nur hass deswegen ist das
eine super entscheidung ich freue mich
total
ist ihn kalt
das glaube ich seine hände sind
schlimmer als alles andere
messen sie seinen blutdruck amanda namen
ich hole sie
okay auf einer skala von eins bis zehn
wie schlimm ist es richtig
mehr als sonst
juli und ich haben uns von anfang an
verstanden denn sie ist 100 prozent für
braun da und das rechne ich ihm hoch an
es ist ein schönes gefühl wenn die
familie da ist und den patienten
hundertprozentig unterstützt
ich muss nochmal den blutdruck dann
können sie sich anziehen
nach dem lasern sind meine hände
angeschwollen die boxhandschuhe die
schwellungen kochen könnte er macht sich
gar nicht klar wofür man alles seine
hände braucht bis man sie nicht mehr hat
der schmerz kotzt mich an aber der frust
ist noch viel schlimmer
[Musik]
nach browns und julis hochzeit wuchs
ihre enttäuschung über die white power
bewegung
ich war total apathisch hat mich für
nichts mehr interessiert nicht wer weiße
schwarze oder juden wir waren die alles
scheißegal da der matte liegen dass ich
nicht alle andern hass auf sondern mich
selbst
juli wurde schwanger das baby wäre
bryans erstes leibliches kind
wir erfuhren dass wir ein kind bekommen
wurde mir klar dass es nicht mehr um
mich wenig da war ein baby unterwegs und
ich musste mit dem partymachen und
rumhängen aufhören das hat mir die augen
geöffnet und mir gezeigt was es bedeutet
ein mann zu sein es war zeit den arsch
hoch zu kriegen
rhein zog sich langsam aus der skinhead
szene zurück er verbrachte immer mehr
zeit mit der familie und immer weniger
mit den ländern ich habe versucht zu
hause essen auf den tisch zu kriegen und
die jungs mussten hinten anstellen sie
hatten einfach nicht mehr den gleichen
stellenwert wie früher die ja die waren
deswegen ziemlich angepisst
was mich blauen jeans der präsident zu
sich rief und mich vor die wahl gestellt
entweder meine familie oder der club
ich entschied mich für meine familie
drohungen und schikanen ließen nicht
lange auf sich warten sie haben um drei
uhr nachts angerufen und gesagt wir
kommen und wohin dich du wirst sterben
seine familie wird sterben
denn die typen mit denen er zu tun hatte
waren dafür bekannt gewalttätig zu sein
und sogar gegenüber den eigenen leuten
war
ständig in alarmbereitschaft
ich konnte nicht mehr schlafen weil ich
angst hatte dass gleich sieben acht
typen meine tür eintreten und uns alle
und ich wollte meine kinder nicht mehr
draußen spielen lassen wie konnte ich
sie auf die straße lassen wenn jeden
moment jemand auftauchen und sie über
den hausherren
dass die kinder darunter leiden mussten
war es aber noch schlimmer war dass ich
genau wusste dass ich absolut nichts
machen kann wenn die zu siebt wird er zu
acht bei uns auftauchen die machen mich
kalt und nehmen sich dann meine familie
vor
und juli waren aus der white power
bewegung ausgestiegen aber ihre alten
bekannten aus der szene ließen sie nicht
in ruhe
was du ihnen jemals anvertraut hast
verwenden sie gegen dich genau das haben
sie bei mir gemacht ich war mit 14
schwanger mir war ständig übel und ich
bekam schlimme krämpfe wir hatten angst
das baby zu verlieren in dem sommer hat
dass du deinen
juli und ich hatten uns wegen ein paar
shirts auf der wäscheleine gestritten
haben die hormone spielen verrückt und
ich war von ihrer schwangerschaft und
der ganzen scheiße mit dem klub total
überfordert ich habe sie und isabella
aus dem zimmer geschmissen und eine
packung tabletten geschluckt
die lehrer pillendosen fragte ihn ob er
die alle genommen hatte
dann schleppte ich ihn aus dem
schlafzimmer die treppe runter und rast
mit ihm in die notaufnahme
das war der blanke horror ich war
schwanger er konnte mich doch nicht
einfach verlassen lass mich nicht
alleine mit dem scheiß ich sagte 'ich
liebe dich' wir haben uns endlich
gefunden
wir haben so viel gemeinsam
ich habe endlich den richtigen gefunden
bei dem ich sein kann wie ich bin der
mich in und auswendig kennt ich wollte
ihn auf gar keinen fall verlieren
wie macht das ständige hochs und tiefs
ich war ein totales war und dann kam ich
in psychotherapeutische behandlung um
wieder platz ich hab dann auch mit dem
saufen gehört das war heftigkeit einzug
ich habe einfach aufgehört das war sehr
sehr heftig
das war seine entscheidung ich habe ihm
niemals die pistole auf die brust
gesetzt dass er aufhören soll nicht
einmal das hat er ganz allein gemacht
[Musik]
morgen baby morgen stürzte
heute ist die letzte behandlung
ich kann es kaum glauben anderthalb
jahre
lange zeit
das ist nicht zu fassen so eine lange
zeit ich kann es kaum glauben dass es
jetzt vorbei ist ich frage mich wie er
sich jetzt fühlt ich weiß warum er sich
die tattoos im gesicht damals stechen
ließ wenn er manchmal so still es dann
frage ich mich wie er sich ohne die
tattoos findet er fand sich damals
hässlich ich finde ihn extrem attraktiv
mit und ohne sie
wir hatten viele extreme fälle hier am
southern poverty law center aber dieser
fall zeigt doch worum es im leben
eigentlich wirklich geht und zwar um
vergebung und erlösung
dieser fall ist ein extrembeispiel dafür
ich möchte mich gern persönlich beim
southern poverty law center bedanken
ohne ihre unterstützung wäre diese große
veränderung niemals möglich gewesen wir
hätten uns das finanziell nie und nimmer
leisten können wir stehen so tief in
ihrer schuld es ist nicht zu fassen ich
muss gleich wollen das war sein irrer
trip ist
kate wird
damit es
ich meine dass sich jemand so stark für
andere menschen engagiert und für eine
fremde familie dass sie so was machen
sowas möglich machen
ich bin so wahnsinnig dankbar
es gab ein paar situationen da wollte
ich alles hinschmeißen und die
behandlung abbrechen da hatte ich keinen
bock mehr es war schon verdammt hart hey
leute
ja klar komm mal kurz vielen dank für
alles
dafür wie ihr euch am ihn gekümmert habe
ich will danke sagen das ist unsere
letzte bahn
wir waren einfach super
nicht holen wir sehen und kennen
bestimmt wir sehen uns wieder das ist
kein abschied für immer genug jetzt
ich weiß ihr seid für uns viele familie
gewohnt
sind sie bereit wenn sie sind dann los
das ist die fünfundzwanzigster
behandlung als wir angefangen haben
hätte ich nie gedacht dass es so lange
dauert es
ist beeindruckend wie er sein leben in
den griff bekommen hat wir sind stolz
darauf eine kleine rolle in diesem
prozess gespielt zu haben hoffentlich
wird die behandlung auf seinem weg
helfen
weder der sich absichtlich solche qualen
aussetzt wird danach auf jeden fall auch
was positives aus seinem leben machen
okay das war's nein wir sind fertig mein
lieber mannschaft das erzählen wir ihnen
nochmal wenn er wach ist für uns war es
das jetzt
das war ein langer weg jetzt noch
verbinden und einschmieren
das war eine interessante erfahrung
haben sie sehr gut kennengelernt sie
gehören fast schon zum inventar man
einfach teil wir haben alle drei ganz
schön was durchgemacht was sie haben uns
gezeigt was familie bedeutet weil schön
wenn man sich überlegt wo wir beide
herkommen das ist kein vergleich
es war uns ein vergnügen sie beide
kennen zu lernen wir werden ihre
gesellschaft vermissen ich weiß alles
klar willst du aufstehen dich anziehen
ich helfe dir
er war derjenige auf dem es ankam wir
haben nur unsere arbeit getan er wollte
diese veränderung und uns war sehr
wichtig ihn dabei zu unterstützen und
obwohl es sehr viel länger gedauert hat
als geplant kann sich das ergebnis denke
ich sehen
ex team hat mich immer mit achtung und
respekt wahren wird sie haben den
menschen winterthurs gesehen in ihren
augen war ich ein normales
passiert mir nicht oft ich habe mich ja
nie fehl am platz gefühlt sie waren
immer so hilfsbereit ich liebe die alle
[Applaus]
von mir
[Musik]
ich hab mein gesicht zurück das ist
super ich bin so glücklich diese chance
bekommen zu haben aus irgendeinem grund
mein gott es gut
[Musik]